[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous pour ce
nouvelle mission dans vie de lecture
avec l'été le soleil arrive aussi
l'envié le temps de lire la lecture
c'est important romain gary disait par
exemple une lecture vous permet
d'échapper à votre personnalité de
devenir quelqu'un d'autre de devenir un
personnage de roman
c'est très vrai aussi pour la poésie
ainsi maltraite donc poète puis grille à
versailles prix du vendée globe mais là
nous nous présenter un niveau lui un
nouveau recueil qui va sortir dans
quelques jours qu'ils s'appellent
l'autre lisière l'autre lisière c'est
notre vie à tous et un jour elle
s'achève elle rentre dans l'autre 10
hier voilà donc 60 de poèmes à peu près
vont paraître dans quelques jours et
c'est vrai que la poésie bon c'est pas
notre lecture quotidienne et c'est
pourquoi puisque je suis là je vais
juste vous lire un ou deux textes selon
le temps que l'on me laisse quand nous
serons terre quand nous serons elle
nuages pluie hui sont nos lèvres comme
un talisman notre souffle comme un
désert
cance enchantera nos silences
s'offriront alors nommé ardente
je suis debout sur l'éternité de la soif
au pan de ma mémoire l'aquarelle des
terres nues le grain les eaux la moisson
est mon voyage définitif
r sur le couchant et je suis debout je
suis debout en longue patience en
transhumance
je suis debout ainsi qu'un autre moi
même voilà donc deux de ses verts qui
seront vus voilà voilà
ah oui ça c'est important la poésie
comme ça suivra après comme j'ai
l'habitude de le faire un roman
mademoiselle se passe c'est le titre qui
vous laisse tout le mystère mademoiselle
et oui mademoiselle il ya de nombreuses
années
ça pouvait être aussi un professeur une
directrice d'établissement des cours
complémentaires
voilà et c'est cette unité rers là que
je vous propose dans ce roman sans vous
en dévoiler rien mais il faudra l'ouvrir
il va paraître dans quelques temps elle
se livre seront au salon du livre nous
auront lieu le 17 novembre
ben oui qu'est la lecture si on n'y met
pas cette infime partie de mystère les
dévoiler je dirais presque pour les gens
qui n'aiment pas trop dire se déroule
alors ça ça me plaît pas je vais pas à
l'ouvrir
tandis qu'à cette petite touche qui vous
dit que peut-être que je vais essayer et
c'est tout l'enjeu de la lecture c'est
tout ce que j'ai appris de mon grand
père qui avait suivi le cercueil de
victor hugo en 1885 et monique au v
conteuse l'association pirouette est
aussi poète donc on doit apprécier l
émission radio l'a voulu nous parler
d'une
en fait là je ne parle pas du tout deux
d'un livre je parle avec l'accord du
millefeuille l'été va arriver je sais
que dans la région il y avait beaucoup
de choses au point de vue culturel qu'il
s'arrête et qu'il ya des gens qui
partent pas en vacances
donc il ya un lieu qui s'appelle le
millefeuille qui attrapent je sais pas
si vous savez où est le single perla
gaouaoui cinéma jean renoir le cinéma et
d'essai c'est de l'autre côté de la rue
et en fait on est du côté de la gare
d'entrée c'est un lieu charmant
emilie est charmante toute l'équipe
aussi
et on peut aller ces librairies
populaire d'ailleurs on peut amener des
livres en bon état et le but c'est de
donner accès à la lecture à des gens qui
n'ont pas les moyens d'acheter des
livres très cher et c'est de l'ordre de
1 euros 2 euros 3 euros et surtout
cerise sur le gâteau l'été il y a des
installé dans le jardin et on peut y
passer l'après-midi et élire et un peu
ce ml est ouverte à tout projet de gens
qui peuvent aller lire des tests
présentés lors les leurs ouvrages
il ya de la poésie et dire des contes
aux enfants aux adultes et j'ai vu aussi
toute fière que les médiathèques les
faire un gros effort je crois cette
année et qui allait aussi avoir des
lectures en jardin alors moi je fais la
promo est de donner envie aux gens
d'aller sur des lieux où ils peuvent
lire les livres s'ils partent pas en
vacances
l'éducation c'est tellement important
mandela disait que c'était la chose
principale du calcul et patrick
ottaviani doc romancier fondateur des
éditions des troupes et marine va nous
parler d'un roman alors c'est plutôt un
récit un récit romancé à caractère
autobiographique qui s'appelle la maison
où mon enfance m'attendais et là c'est
un retour sur les chemins de l'enfance
alors c'est un retour sur le chemin de
l'enfance parce que je pense que à
l'intérieur de nous il ya toujours un
coeur d'enfant qui sommeille certains
l'ont l'on a peut neutraliser y en a
d'autres qui continuent elles laisser
vivre et pour raconter un peu le récit
c'est un c'est l'histoire d'un musicien
internationale qui a passé toute sa vie
à faire des concerts à droite à gauche
sur la terre et que revient la dune
d'une tournée au japon et qui habite
elle en cours il habitait l'encours et
puis sur le pas de sa porte ya le
facteur qui lui tend à un colis et dans
lequel il y a l'album photo de sa
grand-mère et l'album photo de sa grand
mère c'est l'album photo de sa
grand-mère qu'il regardait quand il
était enfant avec elle
60 ans en arrière quand il habitait dans
un petit village qui s'appelait
montlouis sur loire dans un quartier qui
s'appelait les fausses bouteilles et
ce musicien avait complètement oublié
enlever complètement oublié son enfance
même si le coeur de l'enfant qui
sommeille en lui
et d'un seul coup il et s'il prend sa
voiture il va jusqu à rambouillet il
prend la vie prend l'autoroute etc et
sera la sortie 18 amboise et retrouve le
village de son enfance où il n'est pas
laid depuis 60 ans mais le village de
son enfance où le quartier des fausses
bouteilles
ce n'est plus du tout le quartier il a
il est il était il est complètement
changé il s'amuse à faire les boîtes aux
lettres ces pulls et même nom à la place
de de pontus de bouyer de tous les noms
qu'il a connu ce sont le bihan fin et
cetera et cetera
ce sont des mots nouveaux et tout est
bouleversé alors il décide d'écrire un
lead et de ressusciter donc le village
de son enfance avec tous les personnages
qui existait à cette époque là donc il
ya là il ya deux écritures dans ce récit
autobiographique il ya l'écriture de
d'un enfant qu'il retrouve à travers lui
même et lui fait écrire quand il allait
à l'église de mont louis avec ses bouts
part avec ses grands parents
quand ses grands-parents faisait une
partie belote à la maison quand ils
allaient au château de la bourdaisière
parce que c'est son grand-père était
régisseur du château labottière donc
tout ce vécu là de 10 lits à 50 ans
revit et puis dans une deuxième partie
comme si c'était écrit à quatre à quatre
mains il ya il ya le il ya le
contemporain qui fait des allers retours
entre elancourt les fausses bouteilles
en avoir les fausses bouteilles encore
les fausses bouteilles pour voir comment
comment il peut y peut revoir les gens
les gens d'époque et la petite maison
qu'il habitait dans son enfance qui
maintenant elle est bouleversée parce
qu'elle était à racheter la coupe la
ligue
il a retrouvé personnes de ces peuples
de cette époque là certaines maisons
sont à l'identique mais la plupart sont
sans tout changer et puis il ya pu y
appuie les champs il ya plus les vignes
tout a été
tout a été écrasé par le béton et tout
ça donc voilà et c'est aussi lié son nom
au fait qu'il a été il ya une histoire
quand même à travers ça y'a pas y'a pas
que l'histoire de faire ressusciter un
village il ya aussi son histoire
oedipienne à savoir qu'il a été élevé
par ses grands parents
et puis qu'à un moment donné sa mère
s'est remariée à les parties pour
l'afrique et à ce moment-là il après
francis poulenc à tour il est entré il a
été admis au conservatoire il veut il
est devenu un très très grand très grand
rite guitariste il a été acheté par par
radio france
et puis il est parti à travers le monde
et
il à perdre il a perdu aussi le contact
avec sa mère
et ça c'est très très indiquée dans la
grammaire sur patrick hervé va nous
faire voyager aussi vers vers la norvège
je crois un livre formidable s'appelle
les norvégiens ces signes à vibeke knoop
rachline c'est dans une collection qui
s'appelle les ateliers henri d'oublier
ligne de vie d'un peuple
alors je veux pas dire je cherche un
autre mot pour un guide c'est à la fois
un guide est pas un guide tiers
généralement les guides on vous dit
allez manger la fête sylvette ça voyez
si vous voyez sa tête musée machin truc
qu'on brasse or ça ça n'a rien à voir
avec ça du tout en fait ça vous fait
rentrer véritablement dans la culture
norvégienne
ça prend le pouls de cette culture là
c'est ses écrits formidablement bien et
ça comment dire s'est basé sur des
rencontres avec des personnages de
toutes sortes il ya des sportifs ya des
ministres il ya des il ya des cuisiniers
bon bref et chacun y va de son
témoignage et ça fourmille d'anecdotes
et on rentre véritablement dans le ski
c'est la norvège quoi humainement et
c'est ça qui est vraiment pour moi très
intéressant et passionnant
alors j'ai pas le temps de dire la foule
de choses compte qu'on découvre à
l'intérieur de ce livre met
véritablement c'est un regard de
l'intérieur
c'est dommage que j'ai si peu de temps
mais on découvre là le nombre de de deux
femmes
il ya beaucoup de nature on ne renverse
énormément de nature c'est que c'est une
relution il
alors parler décembre et je parle des
femmes adorent se baisser alors il ya
beaucoup il ya eu beaucoup de premières
soit à mon horloge ou est ce que j'aime
sur button en sport des noirs aux yeux
doux à la sauce mal faute disent qu'il a
je sais publié mi temps on va pas avoir
le temps heureux à buenos aires que les
scénaristes réalisateurs et romancier
alors pour clore l'émission je vais vous
parler de patrice franceschi donc
président d'associés explorateur
français prix goncourt de la nouvelle
2015 qui avait le capitaine du trois
mâts d'exploration la boudeuse a fait
deux fois le tour du monde avec son
bateau il a fait aussi le tour du monde
en ulm
donc ça à prince de laventure dans la
lignée des cendrars kessel et il restera
dans l'histoire il est déjà dans
l'histoire
il sera le président d'honneur du 3e
salon du livre d'elancourt le dimanche
24 novembre à la commanderie des
templiers
dimanche 24 mai voilà comment des
templiers salon dont le thème est
aventure découverte nature donc dans ce
livre éthique du samouraï moderne
il a sous titré petit manuel de combat
pourtant désarroi c'est un livre qui
propose une éthique c'est tout
c'est digne des conseils d' éthique à
nicomaque d'aristote les conseils des
titres dépit de tête
voilà c'est vraiment ou sénèque c'est
vraiment important et donc de façon
romanesque
patrice franceschi a recueilli par un de
ses anciens équipiers de marine
il a recueilli les des manuscrits de
toshirô il au guichet un grand
enseignant de l'audio dans le japon et
donc c'est tout une éthique pour être un
bon samouraï moderne
par exemple ils expliquent le courage ne
suffit pas il faut être aussi que en
étant que courageux pour être généreux
ce que hitler avait des gens courageux
qui l'envoyaient à la mort pour de
mauvaises cotes
il faut que le samouraï soit courageux
mais généreux c'est à dire humaniste
avant tout donc qu'ils soient généreux
pour les autres ils se battent pour le
mieux de l'humanité c'est vraiment un
livre passionnant avec des conseils
précis et tout ça voilà un très beau
livre pour l'été
alors merci à toutes et à tous de nous
avoir suivis bon été et bonnes lectures
merci
[Musique]